well for years and years and years we've
been told that wanting a border is
racist only white supremacists want
borders everyone else is an
internationalist
well it turns out that's not true it
never was true but the results are in
its completely untrue
do you know who wants a border
hispanic voters
in 2020 donald trump flipped zapatic
county in texas that's 95 hispanic and
last night if you need more evidence in
a special election a republican called
myra flores flipped a district in south
texas that's 85 hispanic no republican
has represented that district since
1870.
so you have to ask yourself
why are so many self-described latino
voters
voting for white nationalists it's very
odd glenn greenwald has noticed this
trend he's an independent journalist
he's working on sub stack we're happy to
have him join us tonight hey glenn um so
how does this work exactly
it is kind of odd that the media
narrative holds that the republican
party is devoted to a project of white
nationalism and white supremacy and yet
at the same time large numbers of latino
asian muslim and black voters
are either slowly or rapidly migrating
to the republican party which you would
think would make people question
whether that narrative could possibly be
true but you would be wrong it's they're
not questioning it they're essentially
attacking those people by saying they're
too dumb and too primitive to understand
their self-interest
the democratic party and i just know
this from personal experience traveling
a lot does seem like a party that's
wholly dominated by and that caters
exclusively to
the instincts of 45 year old affluent
personally unhappy white women that's
just that's the way it seems to me
so how is that the multi-racial party
exactly
the
split between the reality and what elite
media and uh journalists
and political people have been saying
could not be wider under the trump
presidency trump was held up as this
hitler-like figure one of the two or
three most racist people who wanted to
genocide all non-white people
he attracted more black and more latino
and and more asian voters than any
republican in decades and joe biden won
for one reason and one reason only
because affluent suburban white women
voted democrat after voting for
republicans for a long time it's the
exact opposite of what the media has
been claiming
and it's provable because we have the
election result it's just too
unbelievable glenn graham great to see
we will see you soon
appreciate it
yep good job talking to you tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight